whenever I consider the origin of this
war and the necessities of our position
I have assure confidence that this day
and this union of yours will be the
beginning of freedom to the whole of
Britain to all of us
slavery is a thing unknown there are no
lands beyond us and even the sea is not
safe menaced as we are by a Roman fleet
and thus in war and battle in which the
brave find glory even the coward will
find safety
former contests in which with varying
fortune the Romans were resisted still
left us in a last hope of succor in as
much as being the most renowned
admission of Britain dwelling in the
very heart of the country and out of
sight of the shores of the conquered we
could even keep our eyes unpolluted by
the contagion of slavery to us who dwell
on the uttermost confines of the earth
and a freedom this remote sanctuary of
Britain's glory has up to this time
being a defense now however the furthest
limits of Britain thrown open and the
unknown always passes for the marvelous
but there are no tribes beyond us
nothing indeed but waves and rocks and
the yet more terrible Romans from whose
oppression escape is vainly sought by
obedience and submission robbers of the
world
having their Universal plunder exhausted
the land they rifle the deep if the
enemy be rich
they are rapacious if he be poor they
lust for Dominion neither the east nor
the west has been able to satisfy them
alone among men they covet with equal
eagerness poverty and riches - robbery
slaughter plunder they give The Lying
name of Empire they make a solitude and
call it peace nature has willed that
every man's children and kindred should
be his dearest objects here these are
torn from us by conscriptions to be
slaves elsewhere our wives and our
sisters even though they may escape
violation from the enemy a dishonored
under the names of friendship and
hospitality our goods and fortunes they
collect for their tribute our harvests
for their granaries our very hands and
bodies under the lash and in the midst
of insult are worn down by the toil of
clearing forests and morasses creatures
born to slavery as sold once and for all
and are moreover fed by their masters
but Britain is daily feeding her own
enslaved people and as in a household
the last comer among the slaves is
always the butt of his companions so we
in a world long used to slavery as the
newest and most contemptible are marked
out for destruction we have neither
fruitful planes nor minds nor harbours
for the working of which we may be
spurred valour to and high spirit in
subjects are offensive to rulers
besides remoteness and seclusion while
they give safety provoke suspicion since
then you cannot hope for quarter take
courage I beseech you
whether it be safety or renown you hold
most precious under a woman's a
leadership the brig antes were able to
burn a colony and had not success ended
in supine US might have thrown off the
yoke let us then a fresh and unconquered
people never likely to abuse our freedom
show forthwith at the very first onset
what heroes Caledonia has in reserve do
you suppose that the Romans will be as
brave in war as they are licentiousness
to our stripes and discord they owe
their fame and they turn the errors of
an enemy to the renown of their own army
an army which composed as it is of every
variety of Nations is held together by
success and will be broken up by
disaster these ghouls and Germans are I
blush to say these Britons who though
they lend their lives to support a
stranger's rule have been its enemies
longer than its subjects
you cannot imagine to be bound by
fidelity and affection fear and terror
there certainly are feeble bonds of
attachment remove them and those who
have ceased affair will begin to hate
all the incentives to victory or on our
side the Romans have no wives to Kindle
their courage no parents to taunt them
with flight men have either no country
or one far
a few in number dismayed by their
ignorance looking around upon a sky a
sea and forests which are all unfamiliar
to them hemmed in as it were and in
meshed the gods have delivered them into
our hands be not frightened by the idle
display by the glitter of gold and a
silver which can neither protect no
wound in the very ranks of the enemy we
shall find our own forces Britons will
acknowledge their own cause ghouls will
remember past freedom the other Germans
would abandon them as but lately did the
OCP behind them there is nothing to
dread the forts are on garrisoned the
colonies and the hands of aging men what
with disloyal subjects and oppressive
rulers the towns are ill affected and
rife with discord on the one side you
have a general and an army on the other
tribute the mines and all the other
penalties of an enslaved people whether
you endure these forever or instantly
avenge them the field is to decide think
therefore as you advance to battle at
once of your ancestors and of your
posterity
[Music]
you